if we can't think
greater than how we feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking
and we're thinking in the past so we
call that the familiar past and then a
person gets going in the day and they
start thinking oh i gotta see this
person i gotta go to that meeting i hate
doing this and now they get in their
routine
and a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition a habit is when you've done
something so many times that the body
now knows how to do it better than the
mind so now the person running through
the same routine every single day is on
autopilot and their body's now dragging
them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists is the sweet spot of
the generous present moment that is when
the body and mind are free from those
conditions so along with those emotions
that influence the same thoughts people
start becoming more judgmental they
start becoming more impatient they start
becoming more entitled they start
getting more afraid more anxious more
depressed and now the body is literally
being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all the body's
resources for some threat whether it's
real or imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones is a rush of
energy and so then people use the
problems and the conditions in their
life to reaffirm their conditioning or
their addiction to that emotion and in a
sense they become addicted to the life
they don't even like and this is why
change is so hard hey it's kevin
carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenges holding you back a lack of
belief in yourself you watch these
videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how to brainwash yourself
for success
enjoy
when a person makes up their mind to
change and they say okay i'm not going
to say i can't i'm not going to judge
another person i'm not going to blame
i'm not going to complain i'm not going
to make excuses i'm not going to be a
victim i'm not going to talk trash about
anybody i'm just going to stop well that
works out really well for the first
couple hours
then the body's saying you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you're getting traffic and
you're angry then at 11 o'clock you
check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body's
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just going to
stop today so now the body which has
been conditioned emotionally to be the
mind
wants to return back to its familiar
territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on
this is a good time to judge that come
on this is a good time to suffer it's
your ex's fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so that's when the person makes the
same choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling okay i'll complain
just so i can feel suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy
than step into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process
first of all is not making the same
choice as you did day before
and here's the payoff
you got to stay conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so
the thoughts that they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are
when you when you're distracted by your
environment and you got your cell phone
and your tweeting and your
instagramming and facebook and whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay i'm gonna feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then
if you say then you're not going to live
in the familiar future familiar past or
predictable future you're not going to
think about how long you've been
meditating what you got to do you you
labor
for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that and you
say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now
that's greater than the program and if
the person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy so the person who has the strong
emotion to some circumstance in their
life
and they're
they're working and lowering the volume
of that emotion the more they lower the
volume of that emotion the more they're
going to take their attention off that
person and problem and they're gonna
take their power back there's gonna be a
break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming overcoming overcoming until
we become somebody else and when that
occurs and the person starts thinking
differently
and they start acting differently
and they start feeling differently
they're a new personality and they they
start seeing those synchronicities and
serendipities now
crossing that river of change
the creative process now gets exciting
because what thoughts do you want to
fire in wire in your brain what kind of
attention and intention do you want to
place so that that becomes the loudest
voice in your head and if you keep
practicing it the hardware becomes a
software program and it'll say jay you
can do anything jay
you live in no time and accomplish
everything jay
you're unlimited you just got to hang
with it on the other side of this is
greatness whatever you want to program
in there you get the program in there if
you sat down and say how am i going to
be with my wife my husband my partner
how am i going to be with my kids i'm
going to be at work with my co-workers
how am i going to be in traffic
and you close your eyes and you begin to
rehearse in your mind
if you're truly present the brain does
not know the difference between the real
life experience and what you're
imagining so now the brain goes from a
record of the past to a map to the
future now you're installing the
hardware keep practicing it it becomes
automatic comes easier now it's a
software program you may just start
behaving differently and then if you
said well listen i'm not going to wait
for my healing
to feel gratitude i'm not going to wait
for my new relationship to feel love
i'm going to actually teach my body
emotionally
what that future feels like before it
happens now
this is a big turnaround for a lot of
people because we're so reliant on the
outer world to change our inner world
right waiting and perspiring and waiting
is not creating i mean period and when
people are they could have the greatest
intentions in the world
but if they don't combine that with an
elevated emotion there's no signal
because the elevated emotion is the
carrier it's the energy that carries the
thought
so then
when we're in separation in lack waiting
for our wealth to feel abundance we're
basically living our whole life in pain
right
so then if you reason this and a person
can get up from their meditation and
they literally feel differently
and they're feeling the emotions of
their future before it happens this is
turning
the whole process around
they can't be looking for why would they
be looking for it if they felt like it
they it already happened now there's no
separation now this is
when those serendipities and
coincidences and opportunities begin to
show up in people's lives so it's work
but then when they start seeing the
experience in their life
all of a sudden they
start believing they're more of the
creator of their life yeah and less of a
victim of their life rule number two is
raise your standards with brendan
burchard i know you're always hearing
this advice to raise your standards in
personal development and all the
conversation about success right raise
your standards raise your standards
raise your standards but do you ever
wonder like what exactly does that mean
and where should i raise my standards
because we all know we can live a higher
quality of life isn't it true i mean you
can reach the next level of success and
joy and vibrancy and well-being in your
life we all know that otherwise we
wouldn't strive for it we wouldn't work
so hard if we didn't understand there is
another level of maturity and
consciousness and life for all of us and
i've pursued that question of how do we
get there that next level whatever it is
wherever you're at in your life right
now how do you get the next level well
that's been my study as a high
performance coach for 19 years of my
life and i've strived in my own life to
get there to always push myself to
always sort of level up that next
area of success and joy and vibrancy in
my life and i know maybe as you're
searching too
you just need a little more clarity you
know for what that next level is and i
don't want to give you all your goals
right here and assume what your
standards are but i do know there's five
main areas of our lives i hope you all
have a plan for or an intention for to
get that next level of because when we
get there in these five areas
everything gets better our mission our
work gets better our relationships get
better our psychology our well-being how
we feel about the day gets better so
let's go number one first area to raise
your standards in to get better in to
strive for the next level in is your
health
and you probably don't need me to tell
you that because you probably set lots
of goals every time you know every new
year it's like i'm getting healthier
this year but i hope at one stage of
your life at least one stage of your
life you said you know what
this is going to be
the year that i get the best health of
my life
period
you got to have that year or those
series of years where you're just like
these are the years i'm dedicating get
the best
best help because look when your health
is vibing you've got more energy and
when you've got more energy everything
changes to a brighter hue of color i
mean you see your relationships better
you see your work better you have more
motivation to get through the day you're
more likely to move towards your dreams
because you and i both know when you're
fatigued you're wiped out you're
exhausted you don't get up and you're
like oh i'm so excited you're gonna be
like oh another day
because when it's a brutal fight to
summon the energy you need in your life
it's easy it's easy to quit but when
that energy lives there you can just go
and go and go people ask me all the time
bernie how do you get so many videos
done how do you write so many books how
do you survive on the road i'm like
because i am naturally energized because
i focus so much on my health from what i
eat to how i work out to how i hydrate
every aspect of my life i'm always
working towards improving my health
because you know i want to feel energy
for me the worst feeling is fatigue and
exhaustion and the best feeling is
having a positive buoyant enthusiastic
energy that just lasts so please
if there's any area that you raise your
standards raise your standards on on
what you eat what you feed your family
raise your standards on how much sleep
you expect to get raise your standards
on how much
and how much you're willing to fight and
struggle and work
to improve your mindfulness to improve
your well-being
you deserve to have an experience in
life that is vibrant and you can't have
it unless you raise your standards in
your own health we can all reach that
next level but we have to work towards
it i think the second area we all have
to work towards is our focus
especially these days it's so easy to go
through the day and be distracted by
everything and you and i both know that
that's a challenge you know you click
this little blue link and you look at
that facebook post you read this thing
over here you go to this blog you watch
that video and four or five hours go by
and you're like
why am i naked you know it's like you
lose all
it's like you got a you know a drug and
it just wipes you out for a couple hours
and that's the drug of distraction and
it's ruining people's lives and they're
addicted to it
and so you've got to get your addiction
for distraction under control you need
to raise your standards on your focus
okay i'm only going to focus in this
next hour only on this i'm not going to
check in like an addict and do all these
other things i'm going to focus get this
thing done
make it happen and get rid of all these
beliefs that you can multitask your way
to success today the problem with
multitasking is every area that you open
up to multitask opens up a new door for
distraction today those who succeed the
best are the most focused the most
mindful to what they should be doing
at this moment so return to that return
to what is i want of this day
what is it i desire to happen in this
hour this interaction this next meeting
and if you can get back to your focus
and really bring your moment your
awareness to this present moment to a
full vibrant presence in the now and
mindfully being aware of where you are
what you should be doing what you're
striving for how you're feeling what
you're experiencing of the world the
more you can bring in that elevated
standard of awareness
the more life opens up to you
i'd say the third thing that we all have
to get down is a higher standard of
boldness or courage
you know what where are you at in your
life right now is a complete indication
of how bold you've been in chasing your
dreams how bold you've been in sharing
your ideas your thoughts your dreams
your visions your needs with other
people how courageous you've been to
fight after you fall down to keep
getting up to keep striving to go for
even when they ridicule you even when
you're disappointed even when you're
hurt even when you just feel like
nothing's gonna line up again the
ability to get up again the next day the
next hour the next moment the next
relationship and trust and try once more
that courage and that boldness if you
don't have that then you're never going
to reach that higher standard of living
which you deserve your family deserves
and your community needs from you we
need more bold leaders we need more
courageous people to call the wrong or
wrong to pursue things that are
difficult to dream of those things that
most people will never dream of because
they're scared they don't know how or
they cannot
you have to raise that level of boldness
to reach that next level of success in
your life no matter how successful you
already are i know if you're watching
this you're already a person who's
driven you you wouldn't watch this video
this long if you were into personal
development self-help psychology or high
performance you're here because you
already have an element of that
the next level for you is letting it out
more trusting in that to have the
courage to follow your heart even more
with a greater level of dedication
that's another level of standard i think
for all of us
next area
is joy
you know so many people are going
through the motions in life right now
and they don't have they don't have a
standard for joy i expect i'm going to
have fun when i shoot these videos i
expect i'm going to enjoy my work i
expect in every relationship every
dinner every meeting we're gonna laugh
i'm gonna tease someone i'm gonna make a
joke sometimes it's not appropriate but
you know i'm gonna go for it because i'm
gonna have a good time in life it is so
short and you hear people say that all
the time but i've been blessed to be
with people who are at the end of their
life
literally the last weeks
days hours or even moments
of their life
and i've sat next to that hospital bed
or that hospice bed as people have died
including people who i deeply care for
and i can share with you very simply
that every one of us looks back to our
life and says
dad i really enjoy it i mean did i live
it
and we want to know that we appreciate
it and we had a level of joy but you
can't bring joy into your life unless
it's an expectation unless it's a demand
of yourself you know if you've ever been
to my events before we get the whole
audience agreement bring the joy because
you must bring joy to your interactions
you must discern and decide to do that
otherwise you'll just go through the
motion you'll show up hey guys how's it
going you know
look relationships and life can be
incredibly boring if you let it be but
if you demand of yourself to have fun at
it and you look for moments to tease to
poke fun to make fun of yourself to tell
a joke to pull a prank to see the funny
in situations then you're going to
experience a better quality of life
and i think that last area that most
people could use a little bit more help
on that would really serve them
is they're
you know it's hard to say and and be
respectful but it's your ability to be
more kind to others
we live in a time when people are so
driven and they are doing so many things
that we've lost the ability to
demonstrate kindness with others because
there's a difference between compassion
and kindness right compassion is you
know intellectually and philosophically
you care for someone you feel for them
you're empathetic for them but that's an
emotion empathy is an emotion kindness
is a demonstration
kindness is compassion
activated kindness is something that you
do for others you demonstrate you show
your kindness shows up in your life when
you're patient with someone even when
you want to hurry them up kindness is
something when you recognize the
difficulty someone's going through and
you acknowledge it say you know i know
you're going through difficult times
right now i just want to let you know i
really honor you and i respect you for
it because i can see you're doing your
best
kindness is saying kind things to other
people it can't be a thought in your
mind you must make it verbal you must be
explicit about it
and we've lost a lot of that in our
culture because everyone's in such a
hurry they're like good job and they
move on and that's all you ever get good
job good job good job and that's all
they hear or amen or good for you but
there's no conversation
kindness comes out in taking time with
people
kindness comes out in having real
conversation with people acknowledging
honoring respecting other people and i
think we all have to work on that we've
gotten into a culture that is very
dismissive
very judgmental very poisonous in its
ability to ridicule or or make fun of or
point out or wrong
and i think there's a lot that is right
in this world and until we raise our
standard to say i'm going to be more
kind to others and i'm going to expect
that kindness as well i'm going to ask
for that kindness as well until as part
of our collective consciousness that we
can all be better with each other we'll
never reach those higher ambitions or
higher standards of service those higher
ambitions of humanity i mean imagine
having more love in your life without
kindness it's almost impossible so if we
want that highest level of every
standard that every
sort of recorded history of philosophy
has ever shown us which is love which is
service which is care and compassion we
must bring in kindness to get there and
i hope you'll do that i hope these areas
get you thinking i hope that you're
setting some goals and look you can
reach another level of standard in your
life
it will take all of these things you
will have to raise your health you will
have to raise your focus you'll have to
raise your boldness and your courage
you'll have to raise your joy you'll
have to raise your kindness all these
things you can do expect that you can do
it set a plan to do it demand of
yourself to do it and every single day
that you're doing you'll start to feel a
different level of charge in your life a
different level of energy and excitement
you'll start to experience what we call
the charge life rule number three is
believe that you're a miracle with john
assarak today i want to share with you
something about life
and i remember
25 years ago when my first son was born
in may of 1995
i felt this incredible
gift that was being given to me
and something weird happened i went to
the bathroom when my
wife's water broke and i showered and i
scrubbed myself
you know from head to toe with a brush
and the thinking that was going on in my
head at the time was for the last you
know let's say nine months or so
this unborn child was in my uh wife's
belly
and uh whatever was happening this
intelligence and and you know nature
doing its thing
i was about to get this gift and i
remember thinking
and i'm not religious just so you know
thinking that god was giving me this
gift right
and um this miracle this just incredible
thing called a baby and i remember
feeling extremely emotional
my life was about to change
and it certainly did i have been
so so so grateful and blessed and
involved every day in the life of my uh
son keenan who was born 25 years ago and
my son noah who was born 23 years ago
and the purpose of this specific video
i wanna
just
focus for just a moment on life
have you really ever given some thought
to what it took what it takes to to give
and sustain life so if we reverse back
you know uh your life
uh for however many years you've been
born to the day you were born and
reversed back around 285 days from when
your mother and father had sex
and the sperm and the egg connected and
the x chromosomes and the y chromosomes
interlocked and multiplied 26 times
until you were born
have you ever considered
the billions of years of evolution to
make that happen the perfection
of that happening many years ago when i
wrote one of my books
i likened life happening to a printing
press imagine
if you are
standing outside of a printing press you
know a company or a building that that
produces books or newspapers
and imagine that in this printing press
or this printing
business there's ink there's paper
there's letters you know the little
letters that you stamp on to things
there's everything that's needed to make
a newspaper or to you know to print a
book
and imagine that this printing
business explodes
and all of a sudden somehow by
miracle it all comes together and then a
book lands
you know on the table right next to you
or on the floor right next to you
the idea of that happening is crazy
right
well
the miracle that you are
is crazy right it's just oh my god what
an incredible miracle you are
that i am that we are
and so today i wanted to just remind you
of the intelligence
that created you the intelligence that
is within you that you are
so
feeling less than
feeling like you're not good enough
feeling like you're not smart enough
feeling like you're not worthy enough
really you are a miracle of life you are
a miracle of creation
within you
the hydrogen the oxygen the nitrogen the
carbon and all the other elements the
atoms and the molecules that make you
you
is nature's perfection
yes with all of our flaws that
idiosyncrasies and challenges and and
things we do great and things we don't
that's the miracle of you you are unique
only one of a kind
you're not supposed to be like anybody
else you're not supposed to feel better
than or worse than less than
anybody else
equal
every day
every minute every hour every month
every year
you are a miracle
why not
act that way
why not feel the miracle that you are
why not be
express love give share understand be
compassionate be empathetic
to another human being
who is a miracle
and take a look all around you
because life is a miracle
albert einstein said you can either live
your life
as if everything is a miracle
or nothing is a miracle
well today
i want to let you know
you
are a miracle
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four stop resisting
change with sad guru why is change in
life so difficult when i was younger i
was excited by change i looked forward
to it as happy when it happened as i'm
growing older
i try to avoid it as much as possible
and not able to cope when it happens it
all depends who is initiating the change
maybe but
is there something like an appropriate
response to change
one reason why change is becoming
difficult as you get older is
you have found cocoons of comfort
there are many comfort zones you created
any disturbance of that
you're disturbed now
when you were young you were not looking
for comfort you were looking for life
now you're not looking for life you're
looking for comfort safety
see when you were 16 18 you had wild
dreams as to what you want to do with
your life
by the time you became 25
you cut down all the frills and thought
this is all not practical i am becoming
practical now all that you happened is
you were becoming a coward but you said
i'm becoming practical and cut down many
things and said if i get a job if i earn
my living this this is okay
by the time you're 35 you're thinking if
i don't get into any trouble that's
enough
you're not looking forward into anything
great happening if i don't get into
trouble that's enough but that's when
you start getting into trouble
so
you are not looking at life with zest
you are looking at life as
safety
the more security oriented you are the
more disturbed you will be with every
change that happens in your life
the essence of
physical existence is change isn't
it isn't it so
everything is changing is there anything
that's not changing
[Music]
everything in the existence is changing
isn't it
the physical existence is constantly
changing
the very essence of physical reality is
change
nothing is constant
even the so-called static states
are dynamic in nature everything is
changing
so if you resist change
you're resisting life
if you want an unchanging life
there's one beautiful place
where nothing changes that's your grave
either
you must go to your grave or you must
get enlightened if you don't want change
[Music]
then somewhere inside everything is same
but otherwise as long as you're a part
of the physical process of the existence
everything is changed there is nothing
that is not changing
see this moment you are inhaling next
moment you're exhaling it's change isn't
it if you don't want change you stop it
so when you resist change you must
understand you're resisting the very
process of life
not just your life you're resisting the
very fundamental process of life
invariably you will invite all kinds of
suffering
if you are living
and you want to be dead
you will ask for trouble isn't it
you must be living when you're living
you must live totally if you want to die
you must do that efficiently this is
inefficient ways of killing yourself
really
unhappiness and depression or
inefficient ways of killing yourself
isn't it so
at least be efficient
i can
give you 10 different ways to die anyway
hussein sagar is there
is it still water in it
okay
so
you need to understand this once you
resist change you're resisting the whole
process of life
and you will create unnecessary
suffering
so once your resists change depression
is a natural process
frustration
when change happens frustration
depression frustration and depression
are
[Music]
on a certain day
the devil
decided to retire
[Music]
because he's retiring
he decided to put all the tools of his
trade
for a garage sale
so he opened up
discount sale
all the devil's tools there's a huge
rush
[Music]
there are all kinds of things anger
hatred jealousy this one that one
everything on the table all of you
people went and bought it up in no time
everything was sold out
in the first hour all his tools
the whole humanity has bought it isn't
it
but he had still one more bag
and
what's your name
lena lena went and asked the devil
what's in that bag
isn't that for sale
he said no no these are the prize tools
just as souvenirs i want to keep them
because they have worked best
to do my job
lina said no i want it please
won't you sell that
devil said no no no these two tools that
i have in this bag
they work so wonderfully well
in my whole career
that i would like to keep them as my
souvenirs
once lina's had many other people joined
behind her and please put it on sale put
it on sale put it on sale
then the
devil pulled out and said okay
if you're giving a good price let me put
it on sale
then it pulled out frustration and
depression and put it on table
these two are the best of the devil's
tools
if you want to destroy your life
frustration you start with frustration
develop into depression
you're there
there's nothing worse than that
you'll work against yourself
and the moment you resist change
frustration is natural
once frustration
comes it'll naturally evolve into
depression rule number five invest in
growth with jay shetty people often ask
me are we born with talent or can it be
developed now if you've ever thought
about this question chances are it's
because you see people like cristiano
ronaldo and lionel messi lebron james
and kobe bryant steve jobs and bill
gates when we see these people at the
top of their game we're wondering were
they born with that or did they make it
happen for themselves are these people
born with something different do they
have some special powers how did they
develop and create that ability i can't
speak for all the great people in the
world but in my small way i can tell you
about a little personal experience maybe
a glimpse of what that feels like i want
to tell you about the first time i ever
gave a speech on stage now today i give
speeches and keynotes in front of a
hundred thousand ten thousand thousands
of people at a time for some of the
biggest brands in the world including
google l'oreal facebook but there was a
time when things were very different
very different i want to tell you about
the first time i ever stood on stage if
you remember your first time tell me in
the comments as well i was around seven
or eight years old and i was asked to
recite a poem in my native language on
stage at school remember i'm only seven
to eight years old i dressed up in
traditional indian clothes and i was
much much
much larger than so we didn't quite all
fit together i i looked like a bit of a
mess but in my mom's eyes i looked
amazing i walked onto this stage i had
my notes in front of me and i began to
sing god i was a terrible singer i still
am and as i began to sing the audience
started to love i was in front of 500
kids my age in my school in front of all
the teachers and every single one of
them was laughing these people were like
rolling around on the floor laughing out
loud like they were just literally going
ballistic i wasn't even two minutes in
and then because i was nervous i started
to look down on my piece of paper to
read the next line because i forgot that
line and i couldn't read anymore no not
because i wasn't literate but because
i'd been crying and my tears had washed
away the words on the piece of paper so
i couldn't even read the next words i
was crying so much now while everyone
else was laughing that my teacher had to
walk onto stage put her arm around me
and walk me off stage as everyone
continued to laugh that was my first
experience of public speaking the
testimonials would have read didn't even
finish his performance looked awkward on
stage not sure we'd have him on stage
ever again today i've been fortunate
enough to speak on stage alongside world
cup winning athletes global ceos and
even interview celebrities and authors
like russell brand and tim ferriss i was
and still am one of the most shyest
people you'll ever meet and it probably
doesn't come across through camera but
the truth is that public speaking and
articulating what i believed in was a
skill that i learned over time and i
want to share with you the top lessons
that got me to where i am today there's
three big reasons as to why i didn't
perform well that day and why we usually
struggle in front of stages or in front
of people number one we usually don't
practice enough i realize that if you
really want to be good at something you
have to invest in it with all your life
you have to become addicted and absorbed
to improvement and growth that means
being open to feedback that means being
open to what the experts have to say
about you it means not being attached to
your ego and how you feel about yourself
but opening up yourself to an expert
group of people to give you insights on
how you can grow evolve and perform at a
higher rate and linked to that is
practice practice practice it's
literally impossible to do something
perfectly the first time you do it the
more you do it the better you get and we
think practice is a cliche that we hear
all the time but actually it's that
truth it's so simple you might miss it
did i miss something here the second
thing we usually get wrong is that we
don't believe in what we're sharing i've
realized that i've grown much more
confident about speaking in front of
people and even in front of you right
now on video because i talk about stuff
that's really meaningful to me that's
really purposeful to me i only choose to
share messages that truly resonate with
my heart and my head and my intelligence
and things that i've immersed myself in
for a number of years everything i'm
sharing these stories these ideas they
aren't just made up to sound good these
are things that i really truly try and
live and practice and embody in my own
day-to-day life and therefore if you
don't really believe in what you're
speaking about if you don't really
understand it if you haven't tried to
live it then you're always going to
struggle trying to articulate it and
even if you get away with articulating
something perfectly that you don't
believe in you'll feel empty inside and
that's why sales roles usually end up
making people feel quite empty because
they're selling stuff and products that
they don't think will change your life
make sure if you're trying to
communicate a message for your brand if
you're trying to sell a product if
you're sharing insights and ideas they
have to be things that genuinely connect
with you internally this this feels
weird are you are you sure this is legal
and the third reason why we usually
don't perform well on stage or in front
of people is because we just think about
ourselves we're worrying about what will
people think about me will people like
me will i look good on stage well i
perform well we're so fixated by how we
look to everyone else that we forget
that we're there to serve that audience
we're there to serve the people we're
communicating with as soon as you
realize and you switch that paradigm
that you're there to serve and make a
difference in people's lives you're now
thinking about them you're now thinking
about their experience i just want to
see you happy that's all this applies to
absolutely anything from photography to
videography to dance to music whatever
it may be remember make sure you
practice learn and invest in improving
yourself make sure you're sharing stuff
that you truly value and believe in and
make sure that you don't make it about
you but about the people you're speaking
to number six master your mind with ed
mylett do you ever think about what you
think about because if you did and if
you took control of that you could alter
the direction of your entire life most
people never take the time to take an
inventory about their thoughts yet our
thoughts control our world our thoughts
are like magnets they literally draw
towards us that's what we obsess about
and so most people never take the time
to analyze what they think about the
most successful people i know are the
most self-aware meaning they're aware of
what they do and they're also aware of
what they think they're aware of how
they're perceived so today's message is
about thinking there's some stats you
need to know number one is average
person you and i have about 75 000
thoughts a day rattling around in this
thing we call our brains and our minds
75 000 of them
the crazy thing is 91 of those thoughts
are identical to the previous day and
are identical to the day before that and
the day before that and the day before
that and then we wonder why our life
seems to repeat itself over and over
again so really the difference in our
life if we have 75 000 thoughts a day
here's the crazy thing 91 of them are
exactly the same
the separation in our life is in those 9
of their thoughts because remember this
these magnets are pretty powerful that's
why i'm always saying that your
obsessions become your possessions
because they do you draw into your life
exactly what it is you think about it's
a physical reality that you attract to
yourself what you think about so the
difference in our life is nine percent
of our thoughts that's why people say
all the time the difference between
winning and losing is so small it's
almost too scary to talk about and
really we've identified what it is it's
nine percent of what we think about
alters the direction of our life so what
i'm here to tell you today is you've got
to hone in and get aware of what you
think about and then alter those nine
percent of the thoughts that are
variable on a daily basis to serve you
because if you don't these thoughts
become like viruses they're viruses in
our minds what happens in a computer
when it gets a virus it slows down it
becomes sluggish it doesn't function at
its optimal level same thing with our
thinking if we don't get those nine
percent of our thoughts to serve us our
lives go in a completely different
direction so remember this you don't see
things in your life as they are you see
things in life as you are and so the
more you alter you the more you begin to
see things differently which is amazing
about this is we control who we are by
what we think about think about this
just for a second wherever you're
sitting watching this the chair that
you're sitting in if you're sitting in a
chair if you're driving in a car and
you're listening to this
that seat you're in
started in someone's mind as a thought
right every detailer with the fabric the
cushions the way it's structured every
single piece of that started in
someone's mind as a thought and then
became a reality by putting out the
pieces together
see everything in life is that way as
well it always begins with a thought
when we think a new thought here's what
literally happens thinking a new thought
literally opens a space up in our minds
in our lives that never existed before
prior to having that thought it's like a
brand new space you've created just by
thinking it and what happens is your
unconscious and subconscious mind goes
to work on filling in that space with
the people places resources and things
to fill it up like a room and an
architect would to fill up that space
and fully furnish it that's the power of
how we think so literally everything
that exists started as a thought in
someone's mind and then became a
material matter and so you've got to
begin to think about the things you want
to materialize in your life on a regular
basis and think about it repetitiously
literally the things that we obsess
about become the things that we possess
in our lives most people those variable
nine percent of their thoughts is the
new thing they're worried about the new
fear they have the new response to an
email they have to make and they never
dictate the terms remember this your
mind is a weapon
and you got to begin to use it and pick
that weapon up and control it most
people are out of control with their
mind they don't point it at something
they let the world point it and they
miss fire all the time so today i want
you to pick up that weapon that is your
mind and begin to point it at the things
you want knowing that it's a magnet that
draws to you the things in your life
that you would most like to have or that
you would most not like to have and
that's where most people make the
mistakes in their life so today i want
you to begin with first taking an
inventory of the thoughts you have that
don't serve you and i want you to write
them down and i want you to eliminate
them step one write down the thoughts
that don't serve you and eliminate them
how do i eliminate them by replacement
you eliminate them with replacement by
thinking a new thought it's as simple as
saying what thought would i need to have
that would serve me to get this goal or
dream or vision that i have and get that
thought write it down repeat it over and
over and over and over again because
there's a part of our brain called the
reticular activating system and it's the
filter that we see the entire world
through i talk about it a great deal in
my book max out your life you can click
the link here there's a little bit of
the description in the bio as well or go
to maxoutbook.com you can get the book
or go to amazon
but i talk about this in the book the
reticular activating system is the
filter through which you see the entire
world it's powerful and so that's why it
filters out all the things in your life
that aren't important to you so that you
can be sane you don't feel the blood
rushing through your left ear you don't
you know you're not conscious of your
breathing a million stimulus would hit
you if you couldn't filter things out
you'd go crazy this allows you to only
filter into your consciousness what is
most important to you and what's most
important to you is what you think about
all the time and it creates a filter for
example that's why if something's
important to you the reticular activator
reveals it to you through vision sound
touch you name it and so for example you
ever buy a new car you've got a new uh
you know blue
honda car all of a sudden don't you see
that car everywhere it's on the third
give me three lanes over other side of
the freeway you see blue hondas all of a
sudden everywhere they were already all
over the road why do you see them all of
a sudden you ever noticed that before
because that's become important to you
because it's it's part of your reticular
activating system now so what if you
could program your mind that the blue
hondas of your life are your goals your
dreams and your visions the way we do
that is repeated thinking looking at our
goals visualizing them seeing them over
and over again so let me give you a
couple tips to do that number one your
smartphone you check about 400 times a
day
400 the most important thing you could
do is on your screen saver program the
thoughts that would serve you the goals
that would serve you that gives you 400
triggers a day every time you pick up
this phone you're looking at your blue
hondas you're looking at what's most
important to you what happens is when
you put that down the ras begins
unconsciously to help filter into your
existence the people the places the
conversations the things that will help
you materialize that space you've
created with the thought it fills it
with the furniture of your life the
furniture of the people places and
things so the second thing is to program
your phone with your goals and dreams
that's 400 triggers a day to begin to
alter those nine percent of your
thoughts that's my challenge to you as
you program that ras what's going to
begin to happen is you're going to be in
you'll literally be sitting in a
restaurant three or four tables over as
you're in a conversation you've ever had
this happen you just can't help but hear
somebody
in that restaurant three tables over you
shouldn't be able to hear them that you
do and sometimes almost drives you crazy
doesn't like i can't get these people
out of my head why is it sometimes you
can hear these conversations in a room
or on an airplane away from you and
other times you can't because somehow
that conversation became important to
you and the ras filters it into you
auditory through your hearing and you
begin to hear it when you're obsessed
with what you want you begin to hear
those conversations when you're not
obsessed you miss them or you'll see
something that you wouldn't see you'll
see the prospect you'll see the
situation you'll see the opportunity
it's literally reveals it's almost like
the matrix it changes our world this is
the power of what we think about it's
the most misunderstood thing in the
world it's literally taking control of
your thoughts and pointing it at your
life and your goals and your dreams as a
weapon to magnetize towards you what you
want so my challenge to you is number
one get control and be aware of the
thoughts that don't serve you and
eliminate them by replacement with the
thoughts that do serve you these
thoughts are the things that you want in
your life we do that by repetitious
thinking and we do that by programming
them in our phone having some sort of
vision board up in our lives you can put
your goals on your mirror in your
bathroom but you've always heard these
things before but you've never
understood why they work so most people
don't do it it works because it
reprograms that filter in your mind to
begin to find those things in your life
if you don't take control of them and
you think you're just going to work your
way into it you will work yet another
year another month another decade and
that life's going to look an awful lot
the same because
we become what we think about and if we
don't alter those nine percent our life
ends up looking exactly the same so my
challenge to you is to program your ras
to write those goals down and to
repetitiously program them into your
thinking as much as you can one thing to
be conscious of is the ras doesn't
reveal to you necessarily what you need
necessarily because what you need has
always been there what it does is it
opens you up to seeing hearing
feeling tasting the things that you need
in order to attract them into your life
the last part of the steps that i want
to share with you is that you've got to
control the beginning and the end of
your day with your thinking and so one
of the first things you need to do when
you wake up after you do your stretching
your prayer your meditation whatever it
is is to take a five minute window and
control your thinking whether you you
know after your meditation your prayer
whatever it is but you take a five
minute window and you visually see your
goals and dreams picture them as videos
in your mind picture them as you
possessing them and see them written
down on a sheet of paper this will begin
to control your mind for the day and
then at the very end of the day what i
do one of the last things i do after my
prayer when i'm laying in bed at night
is i read through my goals and my dreams
i picture them and i allow my ras and my
subconscious mind to go to work on them
when i get my sleep it's going to work
on revealing to me it's playing back the
video believe it or not of my day in my
mind
and it is revealing to me the things
that i may have missed in that day that
could bring those things into my reality
and it helps me wake up ready to get
them as well so if you'll do that where
you wake up you go to bed and when you
check your phone you're gonna alter
those nine percent of your thoughts
these are three key steps on changing
the way you think and we know if we can
change the way we think we change the
nine percent of our thoughts we change
what we obsess about we begin to possess
them that thought opens up a new space
that didn't exist before just like that
chair you're sitting in and we'll begin
to create those things in our lives use
these three steps to change your
thinking and i know if we stacked it up
over a day a week a month three or four
years in a decade the direction of your
life is completely different you see
yourself living like this max out at
rule number seven the last one before
some very special bonus clips is go hard
with tom billy as derek jeter said
there may be people who have more talent
than you
but there's no excuse
for anyone to work harder than you do
at the end of the day whether you
believe in talent or not is completely
irrelevant
everyone should believe in hard work
everything in your life is literally a
result of that you're born an infant a
lump of flesh that can't even hold its
own head up and yet somehow
by practicing by learning by growing
you're able to get better you're
literally incapable of anything when
you're born
every skill that you have in your life
all the things that you take for granted
at one point you couldn't do them so
understanding that humans truly are an
adaptation machine and that they are
capable of acquiring any skill that they
want but it requires hard work it
requires that you do the reps it
requires
that you put in the effort
and at the end of the day the people
that you're going to surpass are not
going to be the people that have less
talent than you maybe they even have
more talent than you it's going to be
the people that you're willing to
outwork
but until you're willing to outwork them
you're always going to be stuck and as
john irving said to do anything really
well you have to overextend yourself and
that's the key if you want to put in an
extraordinary performance if you want to
absolutely
dazzle
people
then you have to do something amazing
you have to be willing to put yourself
out there you have to be willing to do
things that other people think are going
to break you that other people simply
believe there's no way that you could be
able to pull that off that the human
animal just is not capable of the
lengths to which you are professing to
go and when you profess it you have to
be willing to back it up and you have to
put yourself on that march knowing in no
uncertain terms under no circumstances
and for no reason whatsoever would you
ever be willing to back
down
and when you go in with that level of
certainty
then and only then are you actually
going to be able to pull this off
and as billie jean king said
champions keep playing
until they get it right
[Music]
fatigue will literally chip away at your
will to win it is the thing inside of
your mind that weak
voice that tells you that you're not
going to be able to make it the weak
voice that begs you to stop and the weak
voice that promises safety and security
if you would just quit
and here's the worst part about that
it's right
if you quit right now
if you stop
just sit down relax
you're not at risk anymore you're not at
risk of embarrassment you're not at risk
of failure
but you're also not at risk of greatness
and if you really want to achieve
something you've got to find ways to put
yourself at risk of something great
happening you've got to put yourself at
risk of overextending yourself you've
got to be willing to face that you may
die that you may actually fall and
here's the thing for the people that
dismiss that that say they would never
put themselves in that situation then
you have limits
and make no mistake those limits are
self-placed
and for the people that are willing to
push that for people that are willing to
go beyond that for people who understand
there are things in this world that
they're prepared to die for and it is
the thing that they put at the center of
their life it is the thing that they are
living for but they're not gonna stop
and they understand that where the human
mind thinks it will break is far short
of where it will actually
break
but before you can find that point
you've got to be willing to push
yourself you've got to be willing to go
harder and farther than anybody thinks
is reasonable or sensible
that's the path
and so the question is can you be
thought a fool the question is do you
believe in something so much that you
would put yourself at risk like that the
question is
can you face down everyone including the
weak voice inside of your own mind
to make the world come true that you
want to see come true
because at the end of the day nobody's
going to do it for you
so if you're a champion
keep going until it's done
discipline is your missing ingredient
you've got the heart you've got the care
you've got the desire to serve you know
you could be doing more you want to do
it for the right reasons you're not just
here to make money you're here to have
an impact and to grow and do amazing
things
you know you can do amazing things
what's missing discipline
there's just a lack of follow through
it's the constant start and stop and
start and stop and start and stop and
for me there's nothing more
not just frustrating but sad than seeing
somebody who's got so much talent and so
much potential and so much of a heart
and just seeing them not win because
they're not following through because
you're just not doing the consistent
enough work that
you're motivated and inspired and then
and then you're not anymore and nothing
happens
and
one of the only things that saved me
the only one of the only reasons why i'm
here
making these videos and you're watching
and i've had any you know success in
social media
is because i just was disciplined that i
just kept making videos
one of the things i love sharing
is
my journey of youtube because i was not
an overnight success story
uh every month almost i'll post to
my socials of how
i grew month over month
year over year on youtube
and in the first five years i had 7 000
subscribers or so
so five years in five years in of making
content
7000 subscribers
a lot of you already ahead of that a lot
of you
could get there a lot faster than me
you know how do you keep going when
you're not getting traction when in year
one you have a hundred subscribers
i i just had to discipline to keep
making content to keep following through
and 12 000 videos later here we are
and and people can get there faster you
don't have to be
as slow as me you know i took i took a
long time
and i had a lot of issues i was
shy and insecure and introverted and
felt like you had to be
you know type a personality to win and
all of these all of these limitability
all sorts of issues and you can get
there a lot faster than me but it still
requires a discipline to follow through
and do it and i really think it's one of
the only things that saved me
i remember sitting down at a
um
florida outlet mall
and i was sitting there with uh with a
friend and nina was going shopping
and uh
we spent half an hour at a at a
starbucks there while she was shopping
and he said i'm gonna be the next gary
vee of my industry you know in music i'm
gonna be the next gary vee in music
and uh
you're gonna keep doing your thing like
let's you know let's let's keep in touch
and see how we do and how we grow and he
posted
you know three or four years later
on his instagram and he said you know
three or four years
three four years ago i met evan
carmichael at this
outlet mall in florida he had our
picture as the
as the post
and i told him i was going to be the
next gary vee for music and he's going
to do keep doing his thing and and evan
went on and did his thing
and i stopped
i didn't have the success that i said i
was going to have
and here's the thing this guy has
way more talent than i do
and he's super talented in music and
just better camera presence
more energy
more his videos just look better way
more attention to detail
he had
all of this stuff and like a warm
amazing human who cares and wants to
serve and wants to see musicians make
money and turn their art into something
amazing right like he had all of this
stuff
all of it
the only thing he lacked was discipline
and he didn't follow through
and and i see that in so many of you
you've got everything you've got all the
ingredients
it's just a lack of discipline and not
making enough
it's the it's the
lack of
because you're not motivated you stop
and lack of motivation isn't a good
enough reason you have to follow through
so how do you do it how do you how do
you how do you stay disciplined how do
you stay focused when you're not getting
results when you're not seeing the wins
how do you stay disciplined okay so let
me give you a couple things first is
having a really powerful morning routine
this is a struggle for entrepreneurs
because no matter how great a day you
had yesterday today is a new day
no matter how great today is tomorrow's
a new day it's like you're starting over
every day you go to an event or you
watch a video get all inspired and you
expect it to last and then tomorrow you
wake up it's like oh how come i don't
feel the same way as i did yesterday and
then that creates a cycle of
procrastination instead of actually
following through so the morning routine
really matters what is it that gets you
feel inspired motivated
creative ready to go so that you go off
and have a much better day for me two of
the things that i find the most valuable
are in my morning routine one is music
so i put on music right away it's the
fastest way to change your state put on
songs that make you move that make you
dance and make you wanna just change
your state because you wake up tired and
no energy like let's go we got to demand
excellence from ourselves and so music
is the fastest way to get your body into
a different state um
and the second in my morning routine is
to do a believe walk and that's 20
minutes to an hour every day
uh i walk i go to tim hortons i grab a
cup of coffee and uh spend you know two
bucks on it and i think about my day how
do i want my day to go what how do i
want to be intentional about the day so
we're not waking up like an accident
most people wake up like an accident
fall into their day look at other people
load your phone you write other people's
agenda for your time and then you don't
follow through and so
having that as part of my morning
routine really helps me so what is your
morning routine the most important thing
that you need to do is the thing that
makes you feel important
vibrant that today is going to matter
put that into your morning routine
instead of hoping that it happened
that's why i make so many videos too
there's content for you every day if you
need me in your life or you need the
people that i profile there's something
every single day for you across my
channels
so there's no excuse for you not to get
the
the
inspiration and the motivation and the
tactics that you need to make your
dreams happen so that's step number one
is have have a powerful morning routine
step number two is create a calendar you
know what's in your calendar i'm making
videos today because it's in my calendar
today's a tuesday when i'm recording
this and tuesday is my youtube day
there's a lot of stuff happening in my
life there's a lot of stuff happening in
my business
uh
you know right now we're we're at um my
my wife's parents house and they're
delivering a couch
i can see that they're delivering a
couch here
it's driving a couch and and they're
helping i'm here making content because
tuesday's my youtube day
you know there's so many other things i
could be doing right now
if i was left to my own devices i'd say
i have something more important to do i
need to be doing x
but because
this has been scheduled in my calendar
i'm going to follow through and make
videos
how have i made you know 12 000 videos
because it's in my calendar it's been in
my calendar for years to make videos
so create a calendar especially with the
things that you know you need to do that
you're afraid to do i'm still afraid to
make videos guys you know again 12 000
videos later i'm still afraid to make
videos why
because i want these videos to be the
best i've ever done because i want to
show up with more care more heart more
passion
i hope that this is a video that forces
you you know to take some kind of action
i wanted to be the best one that i've
done and so i i mini procrastinate
before making videos on a tuesday every
week i have a mini mini procrastination
the only difference is my
procrastination is you know 10 minutes
instead of
days
10 days and it doesn't happen
right
and so whatever you are procrastinating
on that you know is important that
you're just afraid of you put it in your
calendar and you block off time
and
that allows you the creativity and the
space
and suffocates the excuses
for you not to follow through
and then step number three so one have a
morning routine right that sets you up
to create that gets you inspired makes
you feel like you're important today's
gonna matter
two
you create a schedule for when you're
gonna do the things especially the scary
things on your list and then three you
have to teach yourself that you do the
things that are in your calendar you
said you're gonna do it you put in your
calendar you get it done
even if you're tired even if you feel
overwhelmed you can change your calendar
for tomorrow
or you can change your calendar for next
week
but don't trust yourself or listen to
yourself when you're feeling low
when you're feeling overwhelmed and you
said you were going to do it
you have to go up and do it to teach
yourself because what happens is the
next time you say you're going to do
something you put in your calendar
you don't trust that you're going to
follow through because you haven't
followed through the last 20 times
so be very careful about what you put
into your calendar i know when it's in
there you have to go off and do it
make those three changes in your life
morning routine
create a schedule do what's in your
schedule
the only thing you're missing is
discipline
again you've got the heart you've got
the creativity you've got the passion
you've got the willingness to serve you
know you can do more you want to create
an amazing life for yourself your family
the people around you like you know
you've got this thing you know you've
got this thing
i don't need to tell you this you know
that you've got something amazing inside
you
and yet it's not happening consistently
enough
you have to stop jumping from high to
high to high and and wondering why you
don't feel motivated today there's
nothing wrong with you this is normal
discipline
put it into your life and watch your
entire life change
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to raise
your standards with tony robbins check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you then great ideas are never
going to interrupt you they have to be
pursued and you if you don't pursue them
you're going to get what everybody else
has which is all this fear all this
uncertainty all this stuff won't work
because everybody's focused on what
won't work